what I hope to do in this video is get
even more algebraically familiar with
the Lorentz transformation so that we
can recognize it in its different forms
and start to build our intuition for how
it behaves so let's just write down the
Lorentz transformation at least the way
that I like to write it so let's just
remind ourselves if I'm in my frame of
reference I'm floating through space so
I could say s for Sal's frame of
reference some event in space-time from
my point of view it's going to have some
it's going to have some x-coordinate I
will do that in green and it's going to
have some CT coordinate I can do that in
orange let me do that in orange so the
Lorentz transformations are going to go
from coordinates in my frame of
reference space-time coordinates for an
event to my friends frame of reference
so we could say that's the S prime frame
of reference and her frame of reference
the the event will have space-time
coordinates X prime let me write it this
way X X prime X prime comma CT prime I'm
really having trouble switching colors
today CD prime and so let's just write
it down the way I've written down in the
previous videos and then I'll do a
little bit of algebraic manipulation so
we can recognize its different forms so
if we want to get X prime so we want to
figure out X prime we see that it's
going to be based on the Lorentz factor
times X X minus a scaled version of CT
and the scaling factor is beta and we
will redefine beta in a second so beta
times CT where our Lorentz factor let me
write it over here the Lorentz factor is
1 over the square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared or we could write
it as 1 over the square root of 1 minus
beta squared 1 minus beta squared where
beta is equal to beta
equal to V over C so there you go that's
how we get X Prime and it's going to be
based on the Lauren's factions dependent
on V and of course the rest of this is
going to be dependent on X and CT and so
how do we get CT prime L CT prime is
going to be equal to I'll just write it
right over here CT prime is going to be
equal to the Lorentz factor times and
once again this is going to be the nice
symmetry we talked about times CT let me
do that in orange so see t minus beta
times X beta times X and like I said
before I like to write it this way I
find it easier to remember I find it
easier to remember because it has this
nice beautiful symmetry to it that when
I'm writing for X prime it's X minus
beta times CT when I'm solving for CT
prime its CT minus beta times X and in
both cases I'm scaling by the Lorentz
factor but let's let's manipulate this a
little bit just to understand a little
better and and reconcile with what you
might see with other sources including
say your textbook well we know that beta
is equal to V over C V over C and this
is V over C and so we could write this
as V over C times C this C is going to
cancel with that C and so we could
rewrite this as X prime is equal to the
Lorentz factor gamma times X minus VT X
minus V T V times V times T now this is
really interesting right over here
because if you ignored gamma for gamma
was what was 1 here this is essentially
the Galilean transformation you wouldn't
have it if it was just X minus VT that
was what our just our intuition about
our everyday life about Newtonian
physics would actually tell us and so
when you view it in this form you're
really saying ok well we're just going
to scale that by this Lorentz
transformation which has this
interesting behavior that if V is much
much smaller than the speed of light
well
and this is this whole factor is going
to be pretty close to one and that's why
the Galilean transformations worked for
us for kind of everyday velocities but
then if the gala if the Lord if B starts
to approach the speed of light this
thing blows up and we get a very
different result than with our just
traditional Galilean transformation well
think about what happens over here and
over here instead of staying in CT Prime
I'm going to also divide both sides by C
so we're just solving for time as we
normally associate it with you know not
just a just the T the T prime variable
as opposed to C T prime so let's also
divide both sides by C so you divide by
C there and you can divide by C there
and you can divide by C there those C's
cancel those C's cancel and so we're
left with T prime is equal to the
Lorentz factor the Lorentz factor times
T times T minus now you're going to get
V times X and you can divide by C twice
so over C squared so V X V times X over
C squared over C squared and this is
actually a more typical way both of
these of seeing the Lorentz
transformation the reason why I don't
like this form as much even though this
does have the neat kind of when you look
at it it looks like you're just scaling
up the Galilean transformation is that
you know you no longer see the symmetry
there and you should see the symmetry
there because we're talking about
space-time we're not talking we're not
talk about this independence of space
and time and we saw how the angles in
the Minkowski diagram how those were
symmetric or the angles between the the
regular or the unprimed axes and the
primed axes and so what I don't like
about this is you no longer see the
symmetry while you did see it the first
way that I wrote it and I frankly I find
this harder to remember but let's just
think about what happens here when V is
a very small fraction of the speed of
light well as we already said our our
Lorentz factor is going to be pretty
close to 1 and if V is a very small
fraction of C well then this second this
second term right over here is going to
be pretty close to 0 and
so if if V is a small fraction of C then
this thing is going to get pretty so let
me write this down so so if V is much
less than C then this is going to reduce
to T prime being approximately equal to
because our Lorentz factor is going to
be pretty close to one this is going to
be pretty close to zero so this is going
to be pretty close to T likewise
for V the much lower than C over here
our Lorentz factor is going to be pretty
close to 1 and so X prime is going to be
approximately equal to X minus V T so
for small V's and small could even be
you know the speed of a bullet or even
the speed of the Space Shuttle or or
things that are just much much smaller
than the speed of light 3 times 10 3
times 10 to the 8th meters per second
well it's start that that's why the
Galilean transformations are pretty good
approximation so hopefully this starts
to give you a little bit of tuition
think start evaluating this evaluate
this for V's in our everyday life and
then see what happens when V starts to
approach 0.8 times the speed of light
point 9 0.99 so you think about what
happens to the Lorentz factor and and
and hopefully you'll get an appreciation
for the how this whole thing behaves